philippe couillard nous donnent rendez
vous 6h30
l'heure des vrais pêcheurs à la marina
de roberval mais je préférais la fal
safari l'ex premier ministre n'a
toujours pas remplacé son bateau qui a
coulé l'an dernier tel un prix le de la
débâcle de son parti
c'est donc avec un guide et son garde du
corps que nous partons sakineh la
ouananiche sur le piékouagami vous allez
voir vous président entre 8h30 et 9h30
on va attraper noix de vue celui que
l'on surnomme l'ours dans le milieu
politique sort en fait sa tanière la
transition n'a pas été facile depuis sa
démission comme chef du parti libéral et
député de roberval la défaite ça fait
partie de la politique fort pour aussi
on commence à vivre la vie politique
pour savoir qu'un jour ou l'autre à voir
se terminer
non la grosse différence c'est la chute
radicale durée de vie c'est toujours une
amère monde et tu aimes tu as roulé sans
arrêt de sept jours sur sept et tout ça
de se retrouver tous les coups d'un soir
beaucoup plus tranquille philippe
couillard profite donc de chaque
occasion pour pêcher c'est sa passion
mais pas question de révéler sont leurs
secrets
mais c'est pas compliqué il faut qu'il
faut que je trouve quelque chose qui
ressemble le plus possible la proie
préférée du poisson de très sorcier là
parce qu'on la trouvait boutin 2014 je
pense qu'on avait un bon plan pour eux
qui gérera plus 90% de mes engagements
en attendant que le poisson morde à
l'hameçon
l'heure est à la dégustation adepte des
toujours à la recherche de la recette
pioc d'ailleurs joseph dihn surprise
aujourd'hui la ouananiche fumée que je
vais fumer à la maison
et madame
il faut dire honnêtement c'est trop salé
ou le dit pas assez salé trop sucré
pas trop ça l'était pas
il est parfait pour un
voilà neige tout est dû
max à sa place il faut vous plaisir
l'attend oui
parce que quand on est premier ministre
on n'a pas affaire de l'année
des gens disaient tu auras plus le temps
la page de dix points critiques non pas
du fait de la peine
[Musique]
sa femme commence à trouver qu'ils
passent trop de temps à la maison depuis
quelques semaines l'ex neurochirurgie et
multiplie les rencontres pour esquisser
son prochain défi professionnel tu
cherches points et poste cherche une
fonction une activité à laquelle je peux
apporter une valeur est juste là parce
qu'il fallait nommer quelqu'un là
m'intéressent pas sa maison de saint
félicien est à vendre
il aimerait offrir ses conseils
stratégiques au québec ou à
l'international tant sur des questions
de finances publiques que de transition
énergétique
chose certaine pas question de revenir à
la médecine
ce serait peut-être pas de bonnes idées
de recommencer à faire de la chirurgie
après avoir arrêté un bon 15 ans
le 31e premier ministre du québec mais
aussi une croix définitive sur la
politique je pense que c'est assez je
prends un policier de carrière je pense
un important que aussi que
le dis ça j'ai jamais vu la politique
comme une carrière notamment parce qu'il
se sent enfin libérée du carcan partisan
on n'a plus besoin de se demander quand
on rencontre quelqu'un qu'est ce qu'il
veut c'est un partisan ou un adversaire
ça donne un filtre aux relations
humaines qui prit des efforts ça prend
du temps pour se défaire de sa de plus
être là dedans ça fait le plus grave les
faits les pouilles à refuse d'ailleurs
de se voir comme c'est lui qui a mené le
parti libéral du québec à sa pire
défaite
j'ai mené le québec à son plus grand
redressement financier économique depuis
très très longtemps dans successivement
fier on a mis sur pied des politiques
bien structuré d'ailleurs sont pas
remises en question du tout prenez la
politique culturelle prenez la politique
énergétique ce qui a été annoncé il ya
quelques jours c'est essentiellement les
mêmes cibles qu'on avait annoncé à
l'époque la politique énergétique non je
pense que les gens avaient besoin de
changement dirais que c'est la
principale raison parce que y avait plus
beaucoup d' écoute mon accord pour ce
qu'on avait à dire vers 11h notre
patience et enfin récompense une
première
[Musique]
appelle-moi nani est magnifique
si une belle prise à co-animé
l'ex-politicien imaginé le projet de loi
actuel sur la laïcité fait les couilles
à refuse de jouer à la belle mère
mais il n'hésite pas à servir une mise
en garde dans ce dossier lui qui a
toujours prôné l'inclusion
vous savez l'identité québécoise c'est
aussi la liberté et si on recule la
liberté au québec c'est tout le québec
qui veut reculer et j'en suis persuadé
qu'une société se juge à la façon dont
elle traite les minorités ya but et
d'adoption n'a pas l'intention de se
mêler de la course à la direction du plq
mais contrairement à plusieurs libéraux
qui prennent un virage nationaliste en
raison de l'effondrement du vote
francophone
l'ex-premier ministre croit que son
parti défend déjà suffisamment les
intérêts du québec
il faut faire attention de profs de te
post transformer à nos adversaires
le nationalisme ou le tir et le
patriotisme
il s'exprime de façon différente
l'assainissement des finances publiques
l'émancipation financières économiques
historiques qu'on a accompli elle relève
également de désir de force pour le
début comment se porte le québec huit
mois après l'accession de françois
legault au pouvoir avec avec votre book
beaucoup mieux et il avait vu la cote de
crédit là qui en grande partie à presque
totalité est due aux efforts de notre de
mon équipe qui voit que l'équipe
actuelle continuer dans la même veine ce
qui a d'ailleurs été soulignée par l'
agence de crédit c'est bien
[Musique]
la fin de notre virée sur le lac saint
jean était planifiée pour 12h30 à 12h29
alors que monsieur couillard s'apprêtait
à repartir les mains vides
la chance lui sourit enfin des proches
de colère gigantesque une autre des
ouananiches qu'il pourra faire fumer et
toute une histoire de pêche a raconté
jusqu'à quand la main
ouais
[Musique]
puisqu'on vous souhaite pour le reste du
printemps pour l'été d'autres comme ça
et puis bon temps avec la famille
tranquillement un peu d'activité
professionnelle mec soit en dernier fort
et et on va en profiter
les pires avant tout le monde ni de
passer vos vacances au lac saint jean
puisque la pêche avant ici priscilla
plamondon lalancette radio canada
roberval
[Musique]